what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and phase six of the MCU might not be
all what you think it's going to be if
Marvel Studios is planning on doing what
these reports are suggesting that
they're going to do then phase six of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is going
to be insane and Marvel Studios is going
to switch things up on us in a really
great way now fans are already super
stoked for phase six of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe we have Deadpool 3
The Fantastic Four finally entering the
MCU and of course our two big Avengers
films Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars but
what if I told you Marvel Studios is
kind of going to have a phase within a
phase kind of like a phase six and a
half or a 6.1 phase and this sort of sub
phase is not going to be set in our main
MCU universe that we've known all of
these years but will be set in other
universes in the Multiverse if Marvel
pulls this off and then brings it
together for a grand finale in secret
Wars this could literally be the
greatest superhero event of all time and
that's really what Avengers Infinity war
and Avengers in-game was and of course
Marvel Studios is trying to outdo what
they did before they're trying to go
bigger but they're also of course trying
to go better and Kevin feige the
president of Marvel Studios has already
stated there's no point in going bigger
just to go bigger it all has to make
sense but with what we're going to talk
about in this video today it all really
does make sense and if you want to keep
up to date with the latest Marvel news
be sure to subscribe to the channel and
also if you subscribe and leave a
comment you're automatically entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 so Marvel Legends items
or some DC items winner gets to pick one
item and we pick a winner at the end of
each month also check out our patreon
website and Discord we'll link those
down below now we've heard Whispers of
this before but in a recent report it
gets further backed up that Marvel
Studios is planning on dividing Secret
Wars into a part one and a part 2 event
and understand that we are specifically
talking about Secret Wars we are not
talking about Kang Dynasty being part
one then Secret Wars be in part two
we're talking about Secret Wars the
movie itself being split in half as a
part one and a part two film and yes
Kang Dynasty is kind of going to be the
beginning of where the Multiverse kind
of starts to fall apart and incursions
happen so that could be kind of
considered a part one and then we get a
part two and a part three but it sounds
like a lot is going to be happening
between the Kang Dynasty and Avenger
Secret Wars part 1 and then a lot could
possibly happen between part one and
part two of Avenger Secret Wars and if
this is Marvel's plan it is going to be
so good now right now Spider-Man across
the spider-verse is in theaters and fans
are raving about it and if you've been
following a lot of the news you can see
that it really does look like the
spider-verse is actually going to cross
over into Secret Wars and in a recent
report from Alex P over at the cosmic
circus during their podcast Alex stated
that they've heard that some of the
spider-verse characters will be e in
secret Wars then Alex also stated that
Marvel Studios is having discussions
right now about having Avengers Secret
Wars being two parts and having a phase
about battle World between them meaning
between part 1 and part two of Secret
Wars this sets up something really huge
that could happen something that has
never been done in the MCU we're gonna
see events come together in ways that we
have never seen them before now what we
have heard before is that Marvel Studios
is planning on doing some projects
between the Kang Dynasty and between
Secret Wars that could take place
entirely in other universes across the
Multiverse which is a brilliant idea
because we could have another Avengers
film however it could be about a
completely different set of Avengers or
just an entirely different team
altogether that is responsible for
protecting Earth think Multiverse of
Madness and the Illuminati imagine
getting to see a movie based off of that
universe's Illuminati team a little bit
on how they were formed how they came
together and about what they are dealing
with with the current state of the
Multiverse starting to collapse
essentially all the incursions start
happening and all of these different
versions of King starting to threaten
these other universes and essentially
try to take them over or completely
destroy them altogether because we have
seen visions of Kang or flashbacks of
Kang simply annihilating planets that
he's been on and we saw this in Ant-Man
and the WASP fundamania when Janet Van
Dyne touched his chair so we might get
to see other teams in other universes
start to deal with Kang in their own
universes and the great thing is is that
these teams are going to be variants of
characters that we know and love and
we're also going to see teams like the
X-Men and other universes and teams
where the Avengers the X-Men the
Fantastic Four where they're all a part
of one team working together something
we've been dying for to see these three
major teams Collide and come together
and fight alongside each other that's
what we could be getting between the
Kang Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars
part one now this report from Alex B
hearing that they're considering doing a
battle world event between the two of
them in a separate phase this mini phase
we've been talking about that could be
absolutely epic because what battle
world is in the comics is a world a
planet that has been created and created
by Dr Doom nonetheless but created using
the remnants of a shattered Multiverse
essentially what happens is the
Multiverse does indeed collapse and
reality is destroyed so the remnants
that are left of each of the universes
are put together to form One World this
makes all of the different variants and
characters come together and finally
interact with each other so just imagine
this for the MCU Avengers Kang Dynasty
shows us Kang shows us what he is truly
made of and I mean truly made of because
we should have not seen Kang lose to
Ant-Man in quantumania but anyways we
essentially see Kang win in Avengers the
King Dynasty The Avengers realize hey
this guy is a huge threat and our
Multiverse and our reality as we know it
is in grave danger then an Avengers
Secret Wars part one it's kind of like a
Thanos snap they lose to Kang or many
different versions of Kang and the
Multiverse kind of gets destroyed then
they're left with kind of remnants of
universes that used to be we saw this a
little bit in Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse Madness Doctor Strange went
to a universe that was destroyed it was
still kind of intact but it was pretty
messed up that's what we could be seeing
and we could see the survivors of those
universes who are more than likely just
going to be the Super people get put on
another world filled with the other
survivors the other super people the
other superheroes and teams and this is
where they come together and decide hey
we have to work together to defeat King
and get our Multiverse back to fix the
incursions that have happened and
restore everything and it seems like
this is possible based off of what CLIA
told Doctor Strange in the post credits
of Multiverse of Madness she said Doctor
Strange caused an incursion and they're
gonna fix it now in the comics The
Secret Wars events they do fix them and
one of the key characters in that is
Reed Richards he fixes and essentially
resets the events of Secret Wars the
Multiverse gets restored and Reed
Richards is going to be a pretty key
player in the Multiverse Saga he's
getting introduced in the Fantastic Four
movie in phase six and let's not forget
who he is he is the smartest man alive
that's even how he was introduced in
Multiverse of Madness and I would be
curious to see if more than one read
ends up on a battle world I'm wondering
if we're going to get sort of a loose
adaptation of the Council of reeds which
is basically a big team of Reed Richards
from a lot of different universes so
here's the map the road map of if this
happens in the MCU this is how it's
going to go down we'll have Avengers the
King Dynasty where the Avengers will
most likely lose to Kang and from there
the Multiverse kind of starts to fall
apart between the Kang Dynasty and
Avengers Secret Wars part 1 We could see
movies that take place in other
universes other Avengers teams Fantastic
Four the Illuminati X-Men you name it
then we'll see Avengers Secret Wars part
1 where they will truly lose each
universe will lose including our main
one and Kang or multiple Kings will
truly control the Multiverse and it'll
probably start falling apart from there
the shattered Universe could kind of
start to come together with broken
pieces forming battle world where the
heroes will all get together and figure
out some type of a plan to defeat Kang
or multiple Kings and then we dive into
Avengers Secret Wars part 2 where we
have this absolutely epic huge finale
with all of these different Heroes and a
lot of different variants going up
against a lot of different kangs I'm
sure you can imagine it in your head
it's basically a big Avengers Assemble
scene but with more than one variant of
each character so you could probably see
how this would just be a complete game
changer for superhero movies in general
it would be absolutely insane and I know
they're still writing the script right
now but I do hope they break it off into
two movies and do hope this is their
plan to kind of introduce a little sub
phase in there for phase six but let us
know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below you like it do you
not like it give us your thoughts also
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on the
latest MCU news you can always follow us
on Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf
please